[Music]
there's the jungle this is a whole new
thing nobody told us we add it to a
whole new pitch I'm coming grab by Eddie
morning did you guys see Spencer is that
I think he went back in we gotta go get
it
[Music]
oh my god my joints feel like myself I
came back and things actually got worse
look at this - you have some issues here
the game is busted listen up now this is
a dangerous place you've got to have
eyes in the back
Sam he'll just happen to him
Alyssa's
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since and Evelyn you look like
this
never I think my eyes are a different
color all of you is a different color
strengths and weaknesses linguistic oh
goodness
nunchuks that's new damn that's a good
list weaknesses heat Sun and stain how
is this guy a character in an adventure
game Spencer and Bethany
next adventure is even more challenging
this time not all of you will leave the
gang
[Music]
let's make thoughts when you smell we're
in Bethany it's right here she says oh
my god like I'm a total horse Hey
[Music]
terrible job what are you talking about
passed my driver's test last month
that's good we're not gonna make it
we're gonna make it hopefully we're
gonna make it we're gonna make it
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
what happened yes I'm back I missed you
so much oh my god you guys hi Bethenny
you guys were back in Jumanji still
talking to your friends it's complicated
many I did when we first got together
but we were different people
[Music]
bye hey Anthony this is a Martha and
Bethany mrs. grant Bobby thank you
morning sergeant on you you're not
barging he's barging my little Walker
yeah
did you guys see Spencer Vicki went back
in we gotta go get him
huh what oh you oh my god
you're Spencer's grandfather a weird
Florida thank you my little walk-up did
I die and turn into some kind of a small
muscular boy scout are we dead my show
feels good now look at us okay you have
some cashews here the game is busted
who's the game I'm not yet I don't
wonder yet welcome to Jumanji
the sniffs vet joke is even more
challenging and remember future of
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji as
that barbers boy well we did our we
inhale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the fellows to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity it's
a stupid face you make huh what's going
on you having a heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
[Music]